morning all military tanker drivers will
take to the roads this morning to try
and end the ongoing fuel shortage in
england around 200 military personnel
are involved half of them will be
driving they'll initially be
concentrated on london and the south
east where of course those worst
shortages have been reported our
reporter aisha zahid is at the bunsfield
oil storage facility for us this morning
good to see you asha have we seen any
movement yet
well we've seen one or two tankers
really uh leave here this morning it has
been quite quiet but no doubt we're
going to see many more leave throughout
the day as you said the efforts will
concentrate on getting fuel to parts of
the south east and london which are
seeing the greatest shortages at the
moment and also
the largest queues a number of the
stations i drove past this morning
completely out of fuel
all cues starting to form there already
now there's going to be 200 military
personnel involved in all of this half
of those drivers the other half uh
supporting the efforts uh and they're
going to uh be leaving from here here we
actually saw them have some training
over the weekend them learning how to
fill up the tankers how to fill up pumps
and the government is insisting that the
situation is easing that it is coming
under control boris johnson said it's
debating and that military were only
deployed as a precaution but the petrol
retailers association haven't quite
agreed with that sentiment they say
that the problem is still rife as i said
in parts of the southeast and london
where up to 22 of four ports are
currently dry
but they have said that it has
alleviated and has virtually ended in
north of england in the midlands and
also scotland
aisha many thanks
and i am very pleased to say joining us
now from the conservative party
conference of the chancellor rishi sunai
mr sonak very good to see you this
morning um lots for us to talk about
particularly of course on supply chains
but we'll return to that just a little
bit later why don't we start though with
your big speech today and the big
announcement contained therein half a
billion pounds to get people into work
yes good morning neil i said uh over a
year and a half ago at the beginning of
this crisis that my economic priority
was going to be people's jobs and
today's announcement doubles down on
that a year ago we outlined our plan for
jobs and since then the labour market
has performed incredibly strongly if you
just think back people were expecting
the unemployment rate to reach 12
and thankfully it's less than five
percent it's been falling for months now
more and more people getting into work
record numbers of job vacancies you know
that shows me that our plan for jobs is
working which is why today we're
extending that plan for jobs into next
year to keep supporting people
all of which does suggest no chance
there and people will be will be very
pleased that there is more money to
assist people getting back into work
particularly those who are perhaps
slightly older and looking for work but
doesn't all of this suggest that with
the end of furlough we will have to
expect some pretty significant rises in
unemployment
i said right at the beginning of this
crisis it wasn't going to be possible
for me or quite frankly any chancellor
to save every single person's job but
what i do know is that the interventions
that we put in place have made an
enormous difference as i said at the
beginning of this crisis people thought
the unemployment rate would get to 12
that's millions and millions of people
out of work in fact the unemployment
rate has now been falling for about six
months in a row it's under five percent
we have a lower unemployment rate here
in the uk than america canada france
spain italy amongst others and there are
record numbers of job vacancies so i
think the plan is working now of course
some people are sadly have lost their
job and will lose their job but that's
why i want them to be reassured that we
are throwing literally the kitchen sink
at helping them get a new job new skills
new opportunities and we know that
that's been working over the past 12 to
18 months and that's why we're doing
more of it today clearly as mentioned in
the introduction you are speaking to us
from manchester from the conservative
party conference and one thing i am sure
practically every attendee would wish to
hear from the chancellor and indeed the
prime minister is that there won't be
any more tax rises the manifesto promise
has been broken once can you guarantee
that it won't be broken again
well it was a very difficult decision to
put up people's taxes no chancellor
wants to do that certainly no
conservative chancellor difficult for me
difficult for the prime minister but
just remember why we did that that was
to make sure that our nhs could get the
significant resources that it needs to
help recover strongly from coronavirus
i've missed operations i'll just get on
to that and also alongside that to usher
in some reforms to social care that
governments have ducked for decades and
this prime minister deserves enormous
credit for gripping those and
implementing uh some changes there not
least to invest in our social care
workforce to make sure that they get the
recognition that they deserve and those
things are significant investments 12
billion pounds and we need to pay for
those and that's why we took the
difficult but i believe responsible
decision to do what we did
sure but but at the same time we are
hearing from the local government
association that they are going to have
to see council tax rises perhaps as
large coming close to double figures
nine percent to plug the black hole in
in social care i mean can you guarantee
that we won't have to see a rise in
council taxes
well social care is funded by a mix of
different ways one way is through local
taxes like council tax and the adult
social care precept now that's existed
for years that's one part of the funding
system and the other part of can you
guarantee that government
yes and later in the year we have
something called the local government
finance settlement neil where the
secretary of state for local government
sets out all the plans for local
government for the coming year it
wouldn't be right for me to preempt that
but but what people should know is we
want to put more money into social care
that's why we took the decisions that we
did there will be as i said these are
landmark reforms to cap the catastrophic
costs that people will be liable for
more investment in the social care
workforce more integration between the
nhs and social care and as i said at the
beginning significant investment in the
nhs to make sure that we recover
strongly and work our way through the
backlogs
let's talk supply chain then just
for a brief second
it has been reported that figures from
the industry met with representatives
from the government back in june
about the risks the issues of the issues
within the supply chain they warned
about potential numbers did that meeting
not take place or did the government
just ignore that they had been warned
that this was all coming down the
pipeline
so i'm not obviously aware of the
particular circumstances of the meeting
that you're describing but what i would
say just to put this in context now of
course we're grappling with some
challenges in supply chains uh that you
that you highlighted as did your report
i think the first thing to say is it's
not just here these things are happening
all around the world because of the way
that economies everywhere are recovering
reasonably rapidly from coronavirus
after a period of of having been closed
down that's causing some adjustment
issues which all of us around the world
are working through and with regard to
hgv drivers you'll know in your report
covered some of the steps that we're
taking to alleviate some of those uh
issues not least increasing the testing
capacity of hgv drivers temporary visas
five thousand of which hundreds are
starting imminently you know those are
the types of things
i'm not aware of the particular meeting
you have but it's also worth bearing in
mind that this as i said that there are
a shortage of hgv drivers not just here
in the uk but across europe i think the
last uh data i saw from uh from an
intelligence body said something
hundreds of thousands of shortages
across europe so this is this is a as i
said this is not just an issue that we
are grappling with here it's broader
than that but we are doing and people
should be reassured that we are doing
absolutely everything we can to mitigate
those challenges best we can i suppose
the question is then but you know if we
got started a little bit sooner and all
of this we might not be in the situation
we're in at the moment where both you
and the prime minister are not ruling
out shortages come christmas time
well what we are saying is we're
determined to do everything we can and
we are you know whether it's with hev
drivers or more broadly to ease some of
the challenges that we're seeing in
supply chains so speeding up testing
capacity temporary visas these are the
types of things that can make a
practical difference we are committed to
doing all of those and we continue to
engage with the industry in different
sectors to see if there are other things
that we should or could be doing but i
said we're working very hard to mitigate
as much of the challenges here as
possible whilst acknowledging you know
these are not issues that are confined
solely to the uk many country countries
are saying the same thing i mean
as someone else within your party said
not that long ago it does appear that
the government believes that there isn't
there is an upside to these big
supermarket supply chains being broken
up i mean if that's the case what is it
so i didn't quite understand your
question
upside into what sorry neil the upside
into the breakup of the supermarket
supply chains
a break up of the supply chains
well i i don't think anyone would say
that there's an upside to
you know people struggling with supply
chain challenges and not being able to
get what they want at the time they want
it no one wants to see that i think what
what we have said more broadly is over
time you know one of our desires is to
transition ourselves to a higher wage
high skill more productive economy i
think that is a good thing that's part
of what today's plan for jobs
announcement is about in fact it's
giving people the skills they need to
get well paid jobs now over time that's
that's the type of economy we want to
have which is why people don't want to
just pull as a prime minister we don't
want just to pull the lever on more
unskilled migration now in the short
term that's a pragmatic response to some
of the things we're seeing but longer
term we do want to have people in
well-paid jobs and i think i think
that's probably the point uh whether it
was my colleagues or others have been
trying to make indeed i'm just just on
friday in an interview the prime
minister said this never mind life
expectancy never mind cancer outcomes
look at wage growth what what does it
say of this prime minister's priorities
that he issues you know concerns about
rises in cancer diagnosis he issues
concerns about you know life expectancy
dropping in favor of wages
no i i think that was a
mischaracterization of of what he said
and you started this interview earlier
asking me about tax and and tax rises
you know this is a prime minister and a
government that has taken that difficult
decision on tax precisely because we
want to improve cancer diagnosis and
catch up on all the missed appointments
that people had and just two days ago we
announced i think something like 40 new
community diagnostic hubs across the
united kingdom to do exactly that an
early screening and diagnosis of things
like cancer through mri through
ultrasound because we are committed to
people's health i think we've seen that
over the last year and year and a half
and as as this interview started with
you know we're prepared to do some quite
difficult things on the tax side to make
sure the nhs is well funded and and to
do so that we can do all the things that
you just talked about
just just on taxation though once again
we've seen a fairly significant data
dump of papers this time referred to as
the as the pandora papers pointing out
the president's prime ministers at
billionaires are all taking advantage of
offshore at tax regimes
leaving that to one side i just want to
ask a very straightforward question have
you ever benefited from an offshore
arrangement
no no i i haven't and i think i've seen
these things overnight as well and it's
always tough for me to comment on them
specifically given uh they've only just
emerged and of course hmrc will look
through those to see if there's
something
we can learn but broadly people should
know that we have a very good track
record on on exactly this type of
activity and tackling it we've led the
world in improving the sharing of
information between tax authorities law
enforcement agencies registers of what
are called beneficial ownership it's
something that we you know we are proud
leaders of here in the uk but as as the
paper showed this is a global phenomenon
there's a global dimension to it we can
do our bit but we require other
countries to cooperate with us as well
and you will
continue to expect us to press on that
indeed and i wonder if i can just again
end on on a slightly personal note
you'll have noticed the advice coming
from the police in london um about how
women should behave telling them that
they should flag down a bus
if stopped by a suspicious police
officer i mean you've got daughters
yourself they're quite young but in a
few years time they will be out of the
family home i just wonder what you make
of that advice being given to your
daughter
well
of course we all should be able to trust
the police but the fact that you're even
asking this question i think
demonstrates to me and to everyone that
there's a problem and we need to address
it and you know you've heard lots of
people talk about some of the specific
things we're doing but it probably
starts with everyone and especially men
acknowledging what a problem this is and
making sure that we recognize that
anxiety as you said i have two young
daughters you know when cousins was
roaming around an area where my home in
london outside of downing street is you
know brought this home
we have to recognize what a challenge
this is and and work very hard to
address people's fears
mr cena always good to see on the
program thanks very much for joining us
have a good course
still to come on the programme in a few
minutes time i'm going to be joined by
the british meat processors association
pig farmers are warning that hundreds of
thousands of their animals may need to
be culled
due to a shortage of abattoir workers
[Music]
then at quarter to eight i'll be talking
to the mauritius tourism authority as
new uk travel rules make it a bit easier
to go get some winter sun
at 20 past eight we'll be hearing how
some lockdown drinking habits have
continued
long after restrictions were eased
also making the news this morning
a serving metropolitan police officer
responsible for protecting parliament
and diplomats will appear in court today
charged with rape 46 year old pc david
carrick has been suspended from duty the
alleged defense is reported to have
occurred in september
well in a statement the head of the
metropolitan police crested said this
i am deeply concerned to hear the news
today that an officer from the mets
parliamentary and diplomatic protection
command has been arrested and now
charged with this serious offence i
fully recognize the public will be
very concerned too
now it's been described as the biggest
ever expose of financial secrets we're
just talking to the chancellor about it
a second ago and it does appear to
implicate presidents prime ministers and
even billionaires millions of leaked
files called the pandora papers are set
to cause anger and embarrassment among
some of the global elite financial
dealings in london also come under
scrutiny our international affairs
editor dominick wyckon reports
for decades the rich have used offshore
havens to hide away their money and more
and more investigative journalists have
tried to expose their methods
but never before on this scale
it really kind of pulls back the veil of
secrecy that hangs over this offshore
world
it kind of reveals this global industry
of not just corporate service providers
but bankers lawyers and accountants who
are working quite hard to hide assets to
bend the rules in some cases to break
the rules for those who are wealthy or
powerful enough to pay for it
nearly 12 million confidential files
were leaked to investigators
uncovering the hidden assets of 35
current and former world leaders more
than 300 politicians and public
officials
the documents come from 14 offshore
financial service providers based all
around the world
one leader singled out in what
investigators have called the pandora
papers is czech prime minister andrej
babis
investigators claim he used offshore
companies to buy a 12 million dollar
chateau in the french riviera with two
swimming pools and a cinema
he has rejected the claims on twitter i
have never done anything illegal or
wrong he said but that doesn't prevent
them from trying to denigrate me again
and influence the czech parliamentary
elections
many other members of the rich the
famous the powerful are singled out in
the papers for using the offshore
financial system to hide their money and
avoid paying tax
and one location comes up more than
others despite all the controversy about
london being used to conceal huge
amounts of money the city remains the
destination of choice for many it seems
desperate to park their cash without too
many questions being asked
dominic waghorn sky news
also this morning local politicians have
described an oil spill off the coast of
california as an environmental
catastrophe
an estimated 126
thousand gallons has spread into an oil
slick covering around 13 square miles of
the pacific ocean it's thought that a
faulty pipeline was the cause of the
spill
here in huntington beach our local
response efforts have been focused on
two major priorities
first protecting the health and safety
of our residents and visitors
and second
preventing an ecological disaster by
mitigating the impacts of the oil on our
precious wetlands and wildlife this oil
spill constitutes one of the most
devastating situations that our
community has dealt with in decades
new uk travel rules come into force
today which should make overseas travel
easier for those who aren't fully
vaccinated the so-called traffic light
system has been scrapped let's take a
closer look i will the red amber and
green list will be replaced with one red
list only countries where covid remains
dangerously high
fully vaccinated residents won't need to
take a test before they come back to the
uk if they're returning from non-red
list nations
still a so-called day two test will
still be required for everyone arriving
back in the country
but from the end of month in england
those who aren't vaccinated won't need
to purchase a pcr and will instead be
asked to take a lateral flow test
those not vaccinated will still need to
take a pre-departure test as well as a
post-arrival pcr and we'll have to
self-isolate for 10 days no matter where
they are coming from
and anyone returning from a redless
country will need to pay more than 2 000
pounds to quarantine at a government
approved hotel
you can find out more detail about those
changes to restrictions at skynews.com
or on the sky news app
the transport secretary has suggested
that the government will re-examine
plans to extend the hs2 railway line to
northern england
speaking to the financial times grant
shap said ministers were asking
questions and would no longer blindly
follow the original plans
three people are reported to have died
after oman was hit by tropical storm
shaheen
the storm which had been downgraded from
a cyclone made landfall close to the
capital of muscat
152 millimeters of rain has been
recorded so far that's almost double the
average for the entire year
let's take a quick look at the figures
that show the impact of climate change
uh the top line there showing how
the power in the country is being
generated a little more than a third
coming from fossil fuels at the moment
then you have the rise in global
temperature since records began then you
have the time left until an increase of
one and a half degrees celsius which
many people view as the point of no
return then at the bottom total co2
emissions
in millions of tons
to new zealand now uh which has
announced some of its strictest
coronavirus restrictions uh the prime
minister jacinda ardan announced that
from wednesday two households can meet
outdoors up to a maximum of 10 people
early childhood education will return
and people can move around for
recreation such as beach visits and
hunting
wonderful story this one officials from
the european space agency have signed up
a global star to try and persuade more
girls to take up a career in space
technology
barbie will be taking up a career as an
astronaut to encourage youngsters to
join the space race as shingi maruriki
reports
plastic fantastic and floating
weightlessly in zero gravity
this one-of-a-kind barbie is now for
sale in a special week aimed at
encouraging girls to become the next
generation of astronauts engineers and
space scientists
the woman the doll is modeled on is
italian astronaut samantha cristo
ferretti
she'll break new ground next year by
becoming the first european to command
the international space station
she hopes seeing her mini-me could mean
liftoff for the dreams of both girls and
boys interested in following in her boot
prints
i think boys and girls they became
passionate about things because they get
excited because they see something
intriguing because they see something
funny and so maybe those images will
kindle a sparkle of passion in some
girl's heart and and that would be
incredible
the mini samantha doll has already been
on a parabolic flight that means flying
in special airplanes that will draw in
the sky
a parabola shaped trajectory and for
about 20 seconds inside the cabin of the
aircraft you are actually weightless
which means you are floating around in
the cabin just like i will be floating
weightless inside the space station
samantha's mission will see her
following the footsteps of another
european britain's very own helen
sharman who spent eight days at a
russian space station in 1991.
this is not the only time barbie has set
her sight on the stars
four years before man was on the moon
this figurine made it to space in 1965.
now a generation later she floats again
seeing her in orbit could be the launch
pad needed for the next crop of space
explorers shingi mararike sky news
time now to take a quick look at the
weather
and it's going to be an unsettled start
to the week with another area of wet and
windy weather pushing in tonight
conditions will settle from the middle
of the week onwards however many central
eastern and northeastern parts will have
a chilly but bright start to the day
rain over east anglia and the southeast
will clear early on the showers over
western parts of the country will become
more widespread
spreading to all parts it will continue
to be breezy but winds will be lighter
than yesterday temperatures ranging from
13 to 17 degrees celsius the cloud will
thicken in the southwest later as low
pressure brings heavy rain and gills to
the southwest
now spain's prime minister has vowed to
rebuild the island of la palma following
a volcanic eruption that began
two weeks ago well this footage shows
how the eruption is gathered force
following the collapse of cumbria
vieja's north side
local media says the collapse has formed
a new lava flow that is threatening
several nearby times prime minister
pedro sanchez has announced an aid
package of 176 million pounds during his
third visit to the island military
tanker drivers will take to the roads
this morning and attempt to end the
ongoing fuel shortage in england well
ahead of his conservative party
conference speech later i asked the
chancellor rishi sunak if there are some
mps in his party who actually believe
there could be an upside to the ongoing
problems
i don't think anyone would say that
there's an upside to
you know people struggling with supply
chain challenges and not being able to
get what they want at the time they want
it no one wants to see that i think what
what we have said more broadly is over
time you know one of our desires is to
transition ourselves to a higher wage
high skill more productive economy i
think that is a good thing that's part
of what today's plan for jobs
announcement is about in fact it's
giving people the skills they need to
get well-paid jobs now over time that's
that's the type of economy want to have
which is why people don't want to just
pull as a prime minister we don't want
just to pull the lever on more unskilled
migration now in the short term that's a
pragmatic response to some of the things
we're seeing but longer term we do want
to have people in well-paid jobs and i
think i think that's probably the point
whether it was my colleagues or others
have been trying to make
well over the weekend the prime minister
refused to rule out further tax rises i
asked the chancellor if that was
something we need to now expect
it was a very difficult decision to
put up people's taxes no chance it wants
to do that certainly no conservative
chancellor difficult for me difficult
for the prime minister but just remember
why we did that that was to make sure
that our nhs could get the significant
resources that it needs to help recover
strongly from coronavirus we are hearing
from the local government association
that they are going to have to see
council tax rises perhaps as large
coming close to double figures nine
percent to plug the black hole in social
care i mean can you guarantee that we
won't have to see a rise in council
taxes
well social care is funded by a mix of
different ways one way is through local
taxes like council tax and the adult
social care precept now that's existed
for years that's one part of the funding
system and the other part of can you
guarantee that
and we know this well i wouldn't i
wouldn't i can't i can't yes and later
in the year we have something called the
local government finance settlement neil
where the secretary of state for local
government sets out all the plans for
local government for the coming year it
wouldn't be right for me to preempt that
let's bring in our political
correspondent tamara cohen occupying the
very same seat at the conservative party
conference that the chancellor was in
just a few minutes ago
tomorrow what did we learn from rishi
sooner this morning
well neil the chancellor's speech today
is going to be all about how he saved
people's jobs during the pandemic with a
furlough scheme and now that that has
come to an end he's going to try and
help people into work as we recover from
it and he talked about his half a
billion pound plan including measures to
help young people this kickstart scheme
where employers are paid to take young
people on and also to help people on the
lowest incomes and people who are over
50 to up skill for the new jobs that are
available i think you really teased out
the tension that is here at the
conservative conference because they
feel they've in good in good fettle
they've got a good story to tell they
believe about how unemployment has not
been nearly as bad as has been expected
the economic growth is going well but
the backdrop outside here of course is
supply chain problems the fact that
people are going to be grappling with
higher fuel bills higher inflation as we
get to get to the period towards
christmas and you heard the chancellor
there not wanting to suggest that the
supermarkets should have a difficult
time or that you should make people's
lives more difficult but very much
echoing the prime minister's message
yesterday that the governments see these
as bumps in the road as we transition he
said to a high-wage high-skill economy
it is the government's view that if
there are shortages whether it's lorry
drivers or people in food production
that those people should be paid more
money so that you can get local workers
to do those jobs and you don't have to
as the prime minister was putting it
pull the lever of unskilled immigration
and there's a tension there between
wanting to ease the worst effects of
those and not make people's lives
difficult but also wanting to make sure
that in the government's view we can get
over what they see as this bumpy period
and in the end the economy will adjust
to that new reality of course the
question is how long might it take
tamara many thanks indeed
let's stick with a related topic and
there are claims that hundreds of
thousands of cattle and pigs could be
destroyed all because of a shortage of
butchers and abattoir workers
nick allen chief executive of the
british meat processes association joins
us now nick very good morning
good morning
um explain exactly what is going on in
the industry at the moment something
which according to the interview that i
saw at the weekend the prime minister
himself is as yet unaware of
yeah we were surprised that he didn't
understand the situation we've been
talking to government on a daily basis
about the problems we've been having so
uh somewhat surprised that he wasn't
what wasn't aware of the situation we're
short of butchers uh and skilled rock
butchers and these aren't people you can
just pull off the street and and uh
you know put in the process it takes
time to train these people and we're
about 50 10 15 000 pound
people short on um uh the the numbers
that we need uh and we've been asking
the government but we're not asking the
government to go back to the free
movement and uh you know just open the
doors again we're asking them to manage
to help us manage the transition uh and
it takes 18 months to really sort of
train us a butcher and get them up and
up and running uh
so you know as i say we're just looking
for some help here to manage the
transition not actually just pull it you
know just stopping everything uh
overnight really especially on the
background of the pandemic that we've
had where we haven't been able to train
and recruit people mobility of labor has
been a challenge uh and we we have had
this and we said there's a long-term
reliance on non-uk labor which uh uh is
going to take us a long time to adjust
to
but but but isn't he isn't the prime
minister i mean given what you've just
said about the reliance on low-cost uh
on low-cost workforce i mean isn't the
prime minister correct as with this
situation with as regards hgv drivers
that perhaps low wages are part of the
problem here if not the most significant
problem
look we all want to move to we all like
the idea of this high-wage economy and
we've been paying more and offering more
uh and not actually attracting people
and we'll see what comes out of furlough
but the the the numbers that are on
furlough and the numbers that are the
job vacancies we've got uh suggest that
we're still going to have some problems
and we know that there's no butchers on
furlough or anything like that you know
so because otherwise that they would
have already been out there and uh and
and finding jobs so we all support that
but i mean what's interesting is that
they're happy to you know ban the import
of you know the introduction of non-uk
labor into this country that they i
continue to actually aid and abet uh
imported food from countries that have
got access to this labor so um you know
the end of the day someone has to pay
for these these increased wages
and they somewhat get in the way of that
happening by
aiding and abetting some imported food
well nick let's talk about the potential
consequences of those those vacancies
not being filled i mean there are
reports that we could be seeing a mass
cull of animals i mean is that accurate
we know there's a number of a large
number of pigs somewhere you know around
this hundred thousand part no one's got
a handle on the actual sort of figure we
know there's about a hundred thousand
pigs out there that we are struggling to
get processed at the moment and we know
our plants are working at full capacity
as best they can with the labor they've
got so there is a massive problem out
there on farm and we're hearing from
farmers uh all the time we're talking to
the farmers uh you know our members are
talking to the farmers because obviously
they're the people they buy the pigs
from uh trying to manage the situation
so there's definitely a problem out
there uh and uh you know and it's
difficult to see at the moment how we're
going to get ourselves out of this um
difficult circumstances we're in at the
moment
what what then nick do you think that
the knock-on effect is likely to be to
my christmas dinner table something i
have to admit i'm already looking
forward to
the choices and the choices at christmas
will be limited we for some time now
because the shorts of labor being
cutting down the variety of lines that
we're doing to actually keep the uh the
the you know the the plant working at
our
optimal level really so uh the less uh
messing around you do with uh more
refined butchery and things like that so
we've been cutting down the line so be
there will be fewer choices that's of at
christmas that's for certain um and that
that's already started to happen uh in
terms of prices because of the amount of
imported food that's coming in and and
helps uh and the fact that actually
because the the
the farmers are experiencing a lot lower
prices i don't suppose it'll filter
through in costs uh really but that that
is the detriment there's a longer term
uh upshot of all of this that probably
our uk agriculture industry will be
shrinking particularly this little pig
sector and we'll be importing more food
there will be those nick this morning
suggesting perhaps even screaming at the
television that perhaps
you're exaggerating this situation that
the idea that i'm not going to have a
turkey on my table alongside a ham and a
side of beef
is not the reality just ex for those who
are of that opinion make the case
uh look there will be less choices
we're not saying that there's not going
to be food on the table it's on
christmas and and food available but
there won't be the sort of choices uh
you know we're struggling to put the
party thing together the pigs and
blankets the netting of gammons uh the
the the turkey side um but i i suspect
as i keep alluding to uh you know the
food can be imported uh and probably the
turkeys might not be british turkeys but
they may well end up being so french or
even you know sort of turkeys from
further afield you know so the way the
system works in the in in this country
is that um uh you know we're not saying
that the world won't you know there's
going to be desperate shortage of
christmas there certainly won't be the
choices available british food that's
for certain
nick allen chief executive of the
british meat processors association
great to see you this morning thanks for
joining us thank you
now the transport secretary has
suggested the government will re-examine
plans to extend the hs2 railway line to
northern england better public transport
and of course the debate around leveling
up the north of england high on the
agenda at the conservative party
conference but there is a growing debate
inside the party about how it should be
paid for our political correspondent joe
pike reports
how's the new job going how's leveling
up
can you explain what it means to our
viewers
it's supposed to be their central aim
but what is leveling up here's the prime
minister fantastic thank you so much
ultimately it's up to boris johnson to
drive through that reform with money
from the chancellor he's been practicing
his big speech and is due to announce
500 million pounds for a jobs plan later
today
upgrading infrastructure like rail lines
is part of the plan but for some in
manchester it can't come soon enough i'm
pretty sick of like having like dust in
my face if you touch the seats or um
there's not enough carriages or
you know the times aren't regular it's
like it's sometimes i've had to go to
work extra hour earlier just so i can
ensure i'm at work at the right time i
can bring business to manchester and
stuff like that so if the network
transport system is not strong like
people are not gonna want to travel i'm
usually traveling by myself so i'm
mostly okay but i definitely even on the
way down
it was
friday that i traveled
it doesn't seem to matter what time you
get on like it will always end up being
crowded
but how will they pay for it some in the
cabinet are already uncomfortable about
recent tax rises how do you feel about
the possibility of
further tax rises well i think the prime
minister answered that question earlier
on today he said he'd be extremely
reluctant to do that so i
support what the prime minister said
naturally and you were very
uncomfortable with the national
insurance rights weren't you um how did
you know that
you haven't been listening to gossip
have you how shocking excuse me do you
consider resigning
i'm great supporter of the prime
minister that's why that's why i'm in
office i'm a great supporter of the
prime minister we have a wonderful prime
minister i fully support there are
difficult choices ahead for boris
johnson but for now he's enjoying the
moment
[Music]
joe pike sky news manchester
new uk travel rules come into force
today which should make going overseas
easier for those who are fully
vaccinated the so-called traffic light
system remember that well it has now
been scrapped the red amber and green
list will instead be replaced with one
red list only countries where covet
remains dangerously high
fully vaccinated residents won't need to
take a test before they come back to the
uk if that is they're returning from
non-red list nations
a so-called day two test will still be
required for everyone arriving back in
the country but
from the end of the month in england
those who are vaccinated won't need to
purchase a pcr and instead will be asked
to take a lateral flow those not
vaccinated will still need to take a
pre-departure test as well as a
post-arrival pcr and will still have to
self-isolate for 10 days no matter where
they're coming from
and anyone returning from a redless
country will need to pay more than 2 000
pounds to quarantine at a government
approved hotel you can find out more
detail about the changes to restrictions
at skynews.com or on the app
well one attractive far-flung
destination has eased its own
restrictions mauritius is now open for
visitors let's speak now to john watts
from the mauritius tourism promotion
authority john i was about to say it's
lovely to see you this morning but
looking over your shoulders there i am
nothing but incredibly jealous i suspect
that working for the mortish's tourism
promotion authority it's quite a
straightforward job
well good morning from beautiful sunny
mauritius neil um between the choice of
party conference season in brighton or
manchester and mauritius i think i may
have chosen the right option but as you
say
has just reopened our international
borders as of uh friday
and over the weekend we are being
inundated with british tourists who are
flying in for much needed
holiday rest and relaxation
just explain why mauritius has now felt
comfortable enough to open its borders
in the way that it has
so mauritius has had one of the
strongest uh responses to the kobit
pandemic in fact it went
through a very very hard 18-month
uh international border restrictions
which partially reopened uh back in july
and fully reopened here on friday the
1st of october and the russian
government policy
was to vaccinate first and reopen second
so the country is now at a spectacular
89
vaccination rate of adults it's
also vaccinating
children and teenagers and is also now
going into the booster uh
vaccinations so
the response to covet is world-class
when we reach
those levels of vaccination rates we
decided it was safe to open the borders
and as a result fully vaccinated uh
visitors from around the world are now
able to arrive in mauritius with a piece
of pre-departure pcr test
and then two antigen tests here on
arrival and after day five
it is a remarkable achievement certainly
in terms of the vaccination program but
as i understand it i mean tourism makes
up a big old chunk of mauritius gdp
how bad has it been for the country
having the borders closed in the way
that you've had to
well
that's right tourism accounts for
approximately 25 of mauritius of gdp
around a hundred thousand people uh
directly employed in in tourism the
government stepped in at the very
beginning of the lockdown and
implemented the equivalent of the uk
furlough system for people working in
tourism so
people will have had uh support
throughout the pandemic but now the
borders will be opening hotels are fully
reopening people are coming back to
their jobs and indeed uh just the
overwhelming joy of people uh who work
in the travel and tourism sector here in
mauritius of welcoming the world back uh
to the island
has been a fantastic thing to be part of
um john okay time now for the heavy sale
what is it exactly about mauritius that
should be enticing us all to head there
aside from the 24 degree heat that i've
just worked out that you're enjoying
right now
yeah it's a beautiful beautiful monday
morning here this is just outside the
office
here in the capital fort lewis we have
people from around the world here who
have come
for holidays to discover more so not
just uh the beach the lagoons and the
water sports but mauritius is more than
just a beach it is a country there are a
huge amount of things to do here ranging
from hiking in the mountains uh to
world-class cuisine mauritius has a
fantastic mix of
cultures from india africa china and
europe and it all comes together in this
wonderful piece of paradise in the
indian ocean
john is there any part of you though
that is concerned that there may well be
in the future some point in the medium
to long-term future and need to bring
those restrictions back in
i think in the end neil what is what is
important for destinations such as as
mauritius and indeed
the global uh travel and tourism sector
is to work together to share information
and to share data
and in the end it is up to the
individual traveler do they feel safe
and secure
and have access to information to make
their own personal choices on whether
they should travel and indeed back in
the uk there are uh hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people
directly uh linked
to travel whether that be in the
airlines or the tour operators and just
as it's a relief for
the travel sector here in mauritius so
it is in in the uk so
we continue to monitor the figures
we have uh world-class health service
and provision here we're continuing the
vaccination
vaccination program and the more the
world
works together the more that vaccines
are shared fairly and equally around the
world the safer we will be and that is
the priority of the mauritian government
for example investing seven percent of
gb gdp into the pharmaceutical industry
so that we can help get and distribute
vaccines from mauritius uh
across africa who unfortunately are not
in such a great position as malicious
um john we will let you get back to the
my ties do get in touch if there's any
opportunities for breakfast news
presenters in mauritius but for now
thanks very much for joining us in the
program this morning
well let's take you straight to
bunsfield at one of the major oil depots
distributing petrol and diesel to london
and the rest of the south east from here
it will be where
some of those military drivers will be
tasked with driving 200 military
personnel we believe going to be
involved
at least half of those will be sitting
behind the wheel will it have a huge
effect uh well there are perhaps as many
as 20 percent uh of petrol stations
across the country without fuel so for
many it can't count soon enough
about a clear day above hemel hempstead
how's it looking where you are
and it's going to be an unsettled start
to the week with another area of wet and
windy weather pushing in tonight the
conditions will settle from midweek
onwards many central eastern and
northeastern parts will have a chilly
but bright start to the day rain over
east anglia and the southeast will be
clearing early on
the showers over western parts of the
country will become more widespread
uh coming to all parts of the country it
will continue to be breezy but winds
will be lighter than yesterday
temperatures ranging from 13 degrees to
17 degrees celsius